quel jeu de paume et le plus sucré
lequel est le plus acide les sens des
visiteurs des fermes de gally ont été
mis à contribution ce week-end et plus
précisément le goût nous qui sommes à
l'origine du goût de certains produits
parce que sur la façon dont on plante
les produits en les arrosant les
cultivent le produit le végétal pour ce
qui concerne la pomme par exemple va
avoir ou peut avoir un goût différent
et comme on est à l'origine de goût
était important aussi qu'on arrive à
faire comprendre aux uns ou aux autres
donc à partager avec l'ensemble des gens
qui sont des mangeurs pour séparer des
citoyens données économiques le mangeur
c'est vous moi donc de partager avec eux
la façon dont ça se produit et ça ça
fonctionne avec la présence de médecins
nutritionnistes de philosophes ou encore
de producteurs ces universités sont
l'occasion de comprendre d'où vient le
bon goût est d'identifier ceux qu'on
aime ou non il s'agit de déguster et
donc des chocolats et d'en faire une
traduction
de nombreux
un sucre est assez de légèrement dont
camer aussi en fin de bouche en
astringent soir s'il est aussi l'aspect
physique c'est à dire c'est les fins
fonds dans sle
crémeux croustillant ça permet d'avoir
une vision différente du goût et ça
marche très bien si à chaque fois qu'on
essayait un chocolat on faisait une
visualisation en 3d la télé mais que
c'était intéressant puisque la pomme
c'est un fruit qui est très très connu
en fait très répandue on pourrait même
dire que c'est presque banal mais
finalement il ya beaucoup de il ya un
large panel de sensations et au niveau
de la texture au niveau du goût des eaux
de rap
cette journée a rassemblé plus de 300
personnes une troisième édition des
universités du goût est déjà prévue pour
l'année prochaine